شلل تام ضرب القطاع المصرفيه بالعاصمه
الخرطوم جراء المواجهات المسلحه
فجميع البنوك هنا اغلقت ابوابها ما تسبب
في شح كبير في السيوله النقديه لدى
المواطنين ومن يوم السبت
البنوك وقفه والكهرباء الناس معاني هنا بس
الناس كلهم الناس في حاله بتاعه عدم
استقرار لانه البلد مؤمن
الشلل والتام انعكس ايضا على سوق ام درمان
الشهير الذي يعد المزود الرئيسيه لدكاكين
الاحياء بالسلع والمواد الاستهلاكيه وسط
هذا الاغلاق يظهر هذا الدكان كبارقه امل
لكن صاحبه يشتكي من ان بضاعته اوشكت على
النفاذ
من يوم السبت لليوم مافي حاجه البضائع
عندنا في الدكاكين اللي على المخازن دي
شغالين فيها
مخاوف المواطنين من طول امد الحرب دفعتهم
لشراء السلع بكميات كبيره لتخزينها ما
تسبب في ارتفاع الاسعار يعني
الاسعار غاليه والله بصراحه وما في ذاته
توصيل
بتاعتنا ما قادرين نتحرك
لكن برضو بس نناشد
يجلسوا يشوفوا هل بيبقى شنو لانه البلد ده
كده بنهار وبمشي باسوا لا تمثلوا مناشدات
الطيب استثناء في هذه المدينه فالجميع هنا
يدفعون ثمن حرب يجهلون مالاتها
قيظ للمواطنين هنا ان يقعوا في امتحان
امتحان لا يملك المرء امامه سوى ان يتمسك
بالامل ففي ظل استمرار المواجهات المسلحه
باتت كل القصص تحذر من كارثه انسانيه
وشيكا حسن رزاق الجزيره